the value added to theatre and you know
I know this is a debate that has gone on
for millions of years and overly will
still go ova million Jews is that there
is no experience like it it's live your
live there live there feeding off you
you're feeding off them you know and an
audience sense is that Nets that is an
added value and I don't really care how
technology pushes us forward there's
never going to be anything like sitting
in a theater would like to set a hundred
or a thousand people around you laughing
crying you know doing all those
emotional things that that hopefully
good theater will do for you and my
challenge and the challenge that we have
as an industry is getting people to
recognize that and into you know the
theater and you know the complaint that
I hear I hear to the most about theater
specifically the price and the
accessibility the accessibility I'm
going to go backwards the accessibility
is something as an industry I think
actually technology and the theater
world can marry more there are people
out there that don't know how to get
tickets or they think that getting
tickets are complicated they don't
understand you can go online now and and
I think you know the technology in that
case has helped the theater you know
industry tremendously I mean there was a
day and I'm not that old but there was a
day that I remember the only way you
could get a theater ticket was to go to
the box office now and and now it's it's
we've expanded that so it is it is so
you know amazing to me the idea of it
being too expensive is something that
you know is a challenge to the industry
to and to that I always say my job is to
let people know there are many ways and
many different prices of seeing shows
there's the tkts booth there's a you
know there's there's direct mail there's
email bless we're starting to use that
technology and so I think those two
obstacles when you add it together the
added value is to to get the world to
understand there's no experience like
live here they can't be live streaming
HD filming even the audience that is
listening to
conversation right now it would be it's
not at all like if we were sitting in a
room live and that's the the excitement
of live theater we find that the younger
generation unless they have come been
brought to the theater don't get it it
seems like their grandmothers form of
entertainment and you know to that
personally I have been and I most of my
career have been a big advocate of
getting school children into the theater
and whether that is a Wednesday matinee
where you donate tickets or we have a
program right now with with the city
school system that we choose you know
one school every Wednesday matinee they
get you know 100 tickets some of the
schools do it on merit some do it on
financial need you know each school is a
little bit different but I find and this
is one of the greatest joys that I have
as a producer is watching those kids
watch a show many of them for the very
first time and you can tell which ones
are hooked you can tell because again
they're sensing without any explanation
they're watching someone live I remember
once when I was producing a musical
called jelly's last jam in the lake
gregory hines play Jelly Roll Morton and
we took every Wednesday matinee there
were a hundred in her school in city
school kids that got to see the show and
one Wednesday matinee a couple of kids
didn't realize you know they saw it was
live but they didn't know the decorum of
theater and they were screaming at
Gregory go Gregory yeah my man group you
know and they were just so excited and
he kind of stopped the show and he just
very calmly said you know we are so glad
you are here it is so cool but you know
what's not cool I'm trying to you know
so I'll tell you what man why don't you
like let's do the show that's how this
works and then you guys come backstage
when we can wrap and these kids will
like over the moon and it wasn't because
they were you know rule ism but they
were hooked man I was watching those
kids they were so hooked on to live
theater and I thought this is cool they
had just never experienced that before
you know everything every form of
entertainment these kids a head up into
this point in their life was a movie was
a TV was a video was a you know
something they had never gone and had
that you know oh my god there's a person
up there and they happen to know the
person was yeah I love when that happens
and that's a big huge added value when I
was a kid they were saying the Great
White Way is dead you know they were
calling other fabulous invalid I don't
believe it ever will die because of that
feeling of that that idea that you can't
get anywhere else and I think the
younger generation they may be slower to
get there but you know if we do our job
right we'll get them you know they're
there are those kind of hip cool shows
where it's cool to go and they go wow
this isn't so bad you know yeah so you
kind of get them